And what happens if the Avengers return
you don't think I thought about that maybe we
should call our friends no no no no no no we
can't jump the gun on that we get them in a fight
with the Skrulls they find themselves duplicated
and turned into terrorists
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this will be my full Secret Invasion
Episode 2 video there were a whole bunch of
Easter eggs and references so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a giveaway for Disney plus memberships too
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and post your favorite Easter egg from the episode
Everybody's probably gonna be freaking out about
super Skrulls because it's a huge Fantastic Four
Easter egg and it confirms one of my big theories
so we'll talk about that during the video careful
for spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen
it yet we'll start at the beginning and just work
our way through shot by shot talking about Easter
eggs and WTF moments as we go along starting with
the episode title promises a reference to Nick
Fury and Captain Marvel's promise to find the
Skrulls a home and their failure to live up to
that promise like a broken promise it's the whole
reason why graphic radicalized some of the Skrulls
and orchestrated this whole secret Invasion plot
they explain the Skrulls side of the promise is
that they were going to use their shape-shifting
abilities to work for Nick Fury as undercover
Asians going on missions like him like they were
super Shield agents when shielded was still around
the episode starts with a quick flashback Montage
to 1995 in the events of the Captain Marvel movie
just sort of like a quick recap of how he met the
Skrulls in the first place and what happened to
the Skrulls during that movie there was a lot of
backstory for the Skrulls in the episode and a lot
of references to stuff that's happening in other
parts of the Galaxy 2 which I'll reference because
I think that's connections to what's happening
in future Marvel movies like the Marvels movie
during those events Talos said that there were
thousands of them that had been separated and
the ones on Earth in the first movie were just the
beginning like a very small Prelude to what we're
now seeing in secret Invasion then it jumps
to 1997 in Brixton London Nick Fury has been
wearing his trademark eye patch for a while if you
remember in the Captain Marvel post credit scene
coulson had brought him a bunch of fake eyes and
he was trying to figure out what to do about his
eye this is meant to be the eye patch that he
just continued to wear through the 2000s Nick
Fury needs graphic for the first time when he was
younger and learns about his backstory Gravik's
parents were one of the many different families
that were killed during the Kree Skrull War
or Varra thinks that he should bring him onto
his special forces because of his skills and if
you couldn't tell Varra is also meant to be the
same woman in the one division post-credits scene
who came to recruit Monica Rambeau in present
day for Nick Fury's saber space station who we
see in the Marvel's trailer at the beginning
I was sent by an old friend of your mothers
he'd like to meet with you where
right now when this is going on that's already
happened so she's currently in outer space working
on that saber space station Talos claims that
they weren't able to find a home after they went
looking for the past two years everywhere in the
Galaxy either didn't want them there or they were
kree controlled or crazed sympathetic planets so
it's just meant to explain their failure to find a
Planet for their people in that time we also see a
very young G'iah this is Emilia Clarke's character
when she was young in talos's wife and at this
time he says there are still many thousands of
families of Skrulls scattered across the Galaxy
like not all of them have come to planet Earth
yet this is meant to set up the reveal later
where Nick Fury is like wait a minute you're
telling me there are million Skrulls that have
been living on planet Earth since the snap but
the whole idea is that this intro this speech that
he gives in this rousing call to action it's meant
to be very Avenger style like when he showed up
in the Iron Man post-credits scene to give Iron
Man the speech about the Avengers I'm here to tell
you about something only in this case it's meant
to be tragic because the whole idea in present
day is that it's a broken promise and that's
what's led them to to start secret invasion they
cut from a young Gravik's face to him in present
day immediately after the bombing they just sort
of pick up where things left off in last week's
episode and you also notice in present day graphic
seems very suspicious of G'iah like he doesn't
seem totally friendly to her and later in the
episode too it's like he's kind of watching her
so I think he kind of expects her to turn on him
because she is talos's daughter Talos is able to
rescue Nick Fury in the chaos by pretending he's
a Russian police officer after arresting him and
they still want you to think that Maria Hill is
dead Cobie Smulders' after last week's episode
also came out and said that she is supposed to be
dead now she could be trying to misdirect people
but there was an IMDb listing for her in the
Marvels movie so people thought that she was
going to be in that but then Kobe smolder said
that that was fake she's not supposed to be in
it so that also could be more misdirection so you
can believe what you want to believe we'll see if
you remember during the winter soldier movie Nick
Fury faked his death until they came back later
in the movie so it is always possible that she
comes back as hard to tell we'll have to watch
all the episodes before we find out just do not
be surprised if she does show up at the end the
opening title sequence doesn't change is the exact
same one from episode one a lot of people not fans
of the AR art that they use for this sequence
I explained what all the Easter eggs are during
these different scenes in the opening title so you
can watch my episode one video for that then when
the Russian military are looking for Nick Fury
and all the train cars they might be legit or they
could just be part of Gravik's group of Skrulls
Talos pretending to be a woman literally says
it's more likely that they'd find aliens when she
in fact is an alien Skrull herself she is Talos
they have a long conversation talking about their
backstories relative like Nick Fury talks about
his history as a child growing up and then Talos
talks about the backstory of the Skrulls lot of
exposition during this scene Nick Fury's story was
about riding trains from Alabama to Detroit in how
racism affected their family it's meant to be a
parallel for the way the World Views the Skrulls
in present day when he talks about coexistence
being completely impossible like we try to kill
ourselves humans can't co-exist how do do you
imagine we try to coexist with Skrulls when he
starts joking about his childhood hookups with
Susie in Old Man Jackson's Barn that might be
him just making an old man Samuel L Jackson joke
because in real life he is in his 70s he is an
old man but he uses the whole speech Just to let
Talos know he can tell when someone is lying to
him even if he can't tell immediately if someone's
a Skrull or not Talos then talks a lot about the
Skrulls backstory and what really happened to
their Homeworld skrillos the official story that
they told Nick Fury back in the 90s is that the
kree defeated them on their home planet but about
a million of them were able to escape and Scatter
to the rest of the universe most of them stayed
inside the Milky Way galaxy that's Earth's Galaxy
so this is what the map of the Marvel Universe
looks like kree Skrull space isn't that far from
Earth space what winds up happening though is we
get to Avengers Infinity War Thanos snaps The
Infinity Gauntlet snaps half of the universe
Nick Fury is snapped so he disappears talo says
that he thought that he would never be coming back
and they depended on him to find them a place to
live and there were a bunch of scores like half of
the Skrulls were still around that's when Taylor
sent out a signal to all the survivors to come to
planet Earth because now there was a bunch more
space to live on planet Earth with half of the
people snapped and during the five-year time Jump
about a million Skrulls pretty much everybody with
a few exceptions that survived the destruction
of Skrullos their Homeworld had come to planet
Earth and been living there when the Hulk comes
in Avengers end game and snaps everyone back so
the Skrulls have been hiding on planet Earth for
a while now he says the only Skrulls that did not
answer the call to come to planet Earth were
the ones that lived in Emperor droja's Colony
within the MCU that's meant to be the emperor of
the Skrulls when their home planet was conquered
meaning that he also escaped but a portion
of them stayed with the emperor in a separate
Colony on a different world somewhere else in the
Galaxy so they're meant to be like a completely
different group of Skrulls I think the reason for
mentioning them specifically is because they'll
show up in a future movie at some point it might
have something to do with the hulkling character
we'll see they would include that detail if it
weren't going to mean something in the future
in the comics it was actually Emperor Dorrek
who first decided to conquer Earth he was in
a battle with a Fantastic Four he fought the
Avengers he also created the Super Skrull which
is a big part of this episode like the other
big thing that happens in this episode aside
from finding out that Nick Fury has a white is
learning that they are doing legit super Skrulls
but he wound up dying before they could pull that
off princess faranki took command of the Skrulls
and was the one who perpetrated secret invasion
of the comics within the Young Avengers Comics
hulkling is the grandson of Emperor Dorrek and in
the present day of the comics he becomes the new
Skrull Emperor we'll see if they wind up doing
hulkling at some point we know they're going to
do Young Avengers and they'll be a big teaser
for that during the Marvels movie but I don't
know everybody that's going to be on that roster
they've already introduced most of the characters
that I think are going to be on that team but
we'll see there are a couple others like Hulk
link for instance when they start arguing over
the whole concept of the Skrulls being able to
co-exist on planet Earth I think that's meant to
be foreshadowing for the future of the MCU like
eventually some of the Skrulls will win over the
world government events but it's going to take
a long time like we're talking after Secret Wars
you have to imagine Thunderbolt Ross is going to
become president of the United States by the
events of Captain America 4 and there is no
way no way he would let any Skrulls live in the
United States let alone any other world Nations
so the whole idea is that secret invasion is
meant to be the beginning of Marvel's dark rain
era where things just continue to get worse and
worse and worse for all the good characters we
see Maria Hills casket this is her mother I don't
think we'd ever heard anything about her family
or she haven't referenced her mother or any of
the other characters that were really close to
her outside of the other Avengers characters in
previous Marvel movies separately graphic also
reveals that Nick Fury secretly wants to die like
I'm not going to give him the thing that he wants
and it makes it sound like he really wants to die
they have the Skrull High council meeting remember
gravic took talos's place on the council so Talos
used to be meeting with these different people and
the whole idea is they have this news broadcast
where you see a bunch of world leaders and news
anchors those are all the people that are in this
Council meeting it's just meant to show you that
many of the world leaders of the most powerful
nations are Skrulls in Disguise they've already
kind of secretly taken over the world this is
the head of NATO we have Shooter McGavin who's
playing a Fox News type of anchor like a Jay Jonah
Jameson type of character within the series his
name is meant to be Chris Stearns this is the
British prime minister I'm not sure who surely
is meant to represent and they don't say who
this other person is just another head of some
other nation and the whole idea here is that it's
basically graphic taking control of the council
and turning them to his will towards full-blown
secret Invasion like we need to start now take the
planet the council says they're worried about the
Avengers returning and stopping them when gravic
says he's already got a plan to deal with the
Avengers that's a reference to both comic book
secret Invasion where the Skrull impersonated The
Avengers the X-Men pretty much all the big groups
of Marvel heroes but it's also a reference to
his super Skrull plan to give them super powers
like they'd be able to also Fight The Avengers
to a standstill still the more powerful Avengers
they both gravic the role of Skrull generals now
he's not Skrull Emperor he is the general of this
Council remember this is meant to be a completely
separate group of Skrulls that rule by counsel if
the Skrull Emperor lived on the planet then he
would have final say when Shirley becomes the
lone dissenter and says that they ended up in this
situation because they're aggressive war-like ways
in the past that's a reference to this Kree Skrull
War like because we couldn't find peace with the
kree that's why we wound up in this situation it
is meant to be a parallel for what will happen in
present day like if we continue to try and invade
the earth a full-scale Invasion it will only end
up in the destruction of our race a lot of people
wondering about what graphic whispered to his
minion here because Emilia Clarke's character is
listening in maybe to kill the Shirley character
there's a lot of plans that he's trying to hide
from G'iah's character because like I said I
think that he suspects her and they also want
to establish during these scenes that G'iah is
turning against him slowly and will eventually
help Nick Fury and Talos more part of that is
because gravic literally killed her mother they
start talking about the next phase which is a
reference to Marvel phases but also the next phase
of their secret Invasion harvesting different DNA
the DNA of all these different super-powered
individuals and beings that they've captured
which are all the different powers that they're
going to give themselves as super Skrulls in the
comics the Super Skrull was a single character
and it was mostly a fantastic four base character
who had all of the Fantastic Four's Powers so
the whole idea is they had amalgam of a bunch
of different powers there are also a couple scenes
later in the trailer where you see Emilia Clarke's
character bathed in energy so I think the idea is
that she's also going to become one of the super
Skrulls in addition to Gravik some of the others
then Rhodey comes to London for a world security
council meeting on behalf of the United States
president rodie playing the politician makes some
jokes about putting on his War Machine suit his
armor going out to the delegate from Slovakia you
notice the British prime minister who we now know
as a Skrull is wearing a green necklace sort of
calling it out probably because of their recent
Council decision to go ahead with a full-scale
takeover Earth so she's hiding less being more or
Brazen like we're gonna take over this planet any
day now he meets with Nick Fury to talk about
secret Invasion his joke about the brione suit
being the cheaper of the two suits is because his
War Machine armor suit and Iron Man's armors all
cost billions of dollars each that's how rich
Iron Man is they could blow up all his armors
during Iron Man 3 like it's no big deal what's
a hundred billion dollars who cares they'll get
into that during the armor Awards series with the
real version of Rhodey because I think a lot of
us suspect that this version of Rhodey is a Skrull
and that's why during their meeting he seems like
he's pushing Nick Fury around so much and not
willing to help him out because he's secretly
trying to help gravic pull off secret invasion
they make a whole bunch of references during
their conversation too Nick Fury saying that he
has a higher rank than Rhodey who's a colonel is
that Nick Fury is technically had a higher rank
as director of Shield even though they fire him
during this conversation technically it's the
US president that's firing him if he didn't
know before this the government had been funding
Shield so technically the US president was still a
Nick Fury's boss was saber is that I think that
he'd been running that in the absence of Fury
like saber was meant to be the next evolution
of shield in the MCU even though in the comics
is actually sword but they kind of burned that
during the One Division Series they make a Hydra
reference there's still some Hydra people active
in the MCU like Val is supposed to have ties to
Hydra in the serpent Society who also has ties
to Hydra in the Captain America 4 movie I think
the idea though is that Val used to be core Hydra
and was just able to stay off the radar when Hydra
and shield collapsed during the winter soldier
movie Rhodey claims that he's known about the
Skrulls for the past 15 years and if you look
at the dates that puts it around 2008 when the
first Iron Man movie happened so it sounds like it
was right after the first Iron Man movie when he
learned about the Skrulls for the first time when
He suggests they call their quote-unquote friends
he's talking about the Avengers the reason Nick
Fury says not yet don't jump the gun is because
he also thinks that that's what graphic wants
like if we call them in they start a big war
they start duplicating them and turn the Avengers
into Terrace which is basically him describing the
comic book secret Invasion plot that's basically
what happened in the comics Roti gets all
political on him if you remember Rhodey is now the
right-hand man to the U.S president so he is very
literally a politician and I think part of the
idea is that he's been a deep cover of Skrulls
that they haven't been able to detect because the
longer they hold their human form the harder it
is to detect them and it's just been doing it for
a long time now and he's using his access to the
president to help further this secret Invasion a
lot of people now wondering what happened to the
real Rhodey and when did it become Skrull Rhodey
like when did they make the switch my guess is
it'll have something to do with Captain America's
Civil War like it won't be all this time in the
MCU like he was real Rhodey during the first Iron
Man movie probably the second Iron Man movie but I
think sometime around Captain America Civil Wars
when they'll say Skrull Rhodey took his place
just seems awfully sus they reference Alexander
Pierce from The Winter Soldier movie who was Hydra
and one of the directors of the world Security
Council and a lot of this conversation is just
meant to show you that Nick Fury will literally
have to do this on his own for the most part with
talos's help of course but it's Rhodey trying to
cut him off of the pass like cut him off from any
resources that he might get from the government
Sonia fallsworth then tortures one of Gravik's
men that they've captured from the Russian Square
for more information goes full vow on him proving
that he is a Skrull party time it is it almost
looks like she kind of enjoys that too like oh
hey a party great let's go then G'iah learns
about the super Skrull plan all the different
DNA from powered beings like Groot, Frost Beast
which is from the Thor movies Cul Obsidian from
Avengers Infinity War Extremis from Iron Man 3 in
probably some more superheroes and other powerful
characters in there too we don't see the complete
list like they just show you the computer screen
for a little while so they're probably other
characters on there they've stolen DNA from
they probably got some of the samples of the
frost piece before the events of Thor Ragnarok
when the planets align during Thor the Dark World
the samples of groot's DNA would have been left
after the final battle in Avengers end game in
Upstate New York just pieces of his body that
broke off during the battle cool obsidian's hand
was severed by Wong during Avengers Infinity War
the extremist is from Iron Man 3. they still still
have that research and even though there is a lot
of Fantastic Four Easter eggs with all this super
Skrull plot I'm not expecting to see anything
Fantastic Four characters during this even though
Marvel just canceled their Comic-Con plans because
of what's happening with the strike I think
they were actually going to announce who the
new Fantastic Four cast was going to be at their
Comic-Con panel maybe they'll do that sometime
outside of Comic-Con but hopefully we'll find
out pretty soon there are a couple of the classic
Fantastic Four actors maybe even Chris Evans
coming back as a version of Human Torch during
Deadpool 3 but that's sort of like a separate
thing maybe Secret Wars too because it's a big
Multiverse movie originally the super Skrull was
meant to be one character and his name was color
Emissary of the Imperial strong expeditionary
forces I have been appointed by Emperor amak to
be your new leader he started out as a normal
Skrull soldier in their army decorated for his
bravery his combat ability he won all these
accolades then fell into disgrace got banished
then to tie things more to secret Invasion the
original idea for the Skrulls to pull off secret
Invasion came from Emperor Doric who was the
emperor before princess faraki the person who
actually pulled it off came along bringing it back
around to the Fantastic Four because super Skrull
came from the Fantastic Four Comics basically
originally Emperor Doric is the one who tried
to invade Earth in the Fantastic Four Comics it
was way back in Fantastic Four number two in 1961.
like that's how far back it goes the Fantastic
Four wind up stopping the invasion and then he
basically takes all their powers and grafts them
onto colored making him a Skrull that has actual
special powers whereas most of the Skrulls at
the time only had the ability to change form and
just had basic super strength as part of their
biology their bodies are a little bit stronger
more resilient than human bodies in the way that
all regular as Guardians who don't have special
powers just have stronger bodies and live longer
same thing with Loki's character now like Loki
and Thor are different because they do have actual
special powers like Loki practices magic Thor has
actual Celestial God Powers they're just changing
this a little bit in the MCU version giving all
these newer Skrulls like the younger generation
special powers more evolved bodies after Gravik
stops her from finding more information they go to
rescue the Skrulls that Sonia fallsworth captured
and then killing him outside of their settlement
is just meant to show you how hardcore they are
like okay you gave up information so we're gonna
kill you off right now then probably the other
major reveal of the episode Nick Fury travels to
his secret home they confirm he has a wife and
she is a Skrull now he'd referenced in the past
that he had a house as a private citizen but he
didn't talk about a wife ever I don't think he's
ever referenced having a family himself some of
the Avengers characters probably knew about his
wife like black widow Hawkeye probably figured
it out like that's black widow's whole thing is
information but not all the Avengers and that's
why they have that ritual about him putting his
wedding ring back on because Hattie Warren in
the wedding ring around this whole time everybody
and their sister would have learned that he had a
family she'll be a bigger character in future
episodes like she shows up in the trailer a
couple different places there are a couple
big story lines the big thing right now is
just what's going on with his wife like how's she
going to become a big part of this and the super
Skrull plot like how they going to further that
because there are a couple other big trailer shots
of them stealing other DNA Parts Gravik's group
stealing Parts like cool obsidian's hand because
there are a couple scenes from previous trailers
where you see them trying to steal those pieces
of DNA like I think this is now confirmed to be
cool obsidian's sever at hand let me know in the
comments when do you think that they're actually
going to start turning them into Super Skrulls do
you think they'll save that for the final episode
or like the final two episodes after episode one
there were a lot of people that also theorized
that graphic had some special relationship with
me fury like there was something between them that
they hadn't revealed yet some people even thought
that he might be Nick Fury's secret son I don't
think that's the case I don't think that's what
they're trying to say here but I do think they
want to show the graphic trusted Nick Fury and he
came kind of like a surrogate father to him and
that's why Nick Fury recently taking off on the
space station just being gone for that five-year
time Jump because he'd been blipped feels like
a betrayal to graphic in what drove him over the
edge to actually execute this secret Invasion so
I do think that there's like this really personal
relationship between graphic and Nick Fury that
they haven't fully revealed yet but they'll
probably get a couple really big scenes together
in the next couple of episodes also let me know
in the comments which other big Marvel super power
characters or super powered individuals do you
think that they're trying to steal powers from
to give themselves more Super Skrull Powers
I don't think they'd be able to do it but it
would be really handy if they could somehow get
Scarlet Witch's DNA to give themselves some chaos
magic powers it doesn't necessarily work like that
but if you're grabbing people's Powers you want
to grab the most powerful characters Powers my
secret Invasion Episode 3 trailer video will post
tomorrow in my full episode 3 video will post next
week after they release it there's a couple of the
really big things going on this week too so make
sure to enable alerts for my channel so you don't
miss any of those click here for that episode
three video update the link as soon as I post that
and click here to learn about Ben Affleck coming
back as his version of Daredevil in Deadpool 3.
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!